Hello Freak bitches.
You can converse in like an a type the type of English we're talking right now
almost,
which creates this weird tension between the things that you're discussing and
how you're discussing them.
Like for instance,
to have a guy just in conversational English talking about problems they're
having with neighboring schamens and their own Sharman putting curses on each
other and it like creates like,
there's like a strange tension between like how it's being conveyed to you.
You know,
like how,
so like,
okay,
if you're talking conversational English,
I guess like a life,
it's almost like you'd want it to be when he's telling you this,
you'd almost want to be reading it in like closed caption and he'd be saying it
in the indigenous language because it sounds weird to have to have an idea
that's so foreign to us,
which would be like a battle of schamens battling over access to wild animals.
Okay.
Um,
to have that delivered in conversational English has struck me as unusual.
And because like usually when you're traveling,
you're getting all of your information like traveling and Bolivia,
a guy would tell a story and he'd tell a story in um,
Sim Shyanne no one was staying in that same Shan Chimani.
Okay.
He tells story in Chimani to a person who spoke Spanish.
The person who speaks Spanish would tell it to a person.
No,
no,
no.
Chimani guy telling someone who speaks Chimani in Spanish.
Then that person telling it to a person who speaks Spanish and English and then
that person giving you the information.
When you get it through that it takes on a mystical quality.
Like you're crossing some space time thing,
right.
Where you're seeing like these ideas discussed in their ancestral tongue.
Okay.
Yeah.
Tamara sent you a video of a guy talking about killing a Jaguar.
Yes.
Right.
The language you've never like when he's speaking you're like,
I've never in all my travels,
I've never heard of language.
It sounds anything like that
right here.
Yeah.
I don't want to leave.
You can use a Kombucha bottle.
Yeah,
man.
It's the healthiest for all of the PD.
You've done this twice.
Really?
Yeah.
We've done this on the podcast for great.
For sure.
I liked the fact that you're willing to do that too.
I don't think we could show it on youtube though,
so we'll have to,
we'll have to move away up or he's got his dick out great too.
Cause I got a big opening.
Yeah.
So it doesn't vacuum up.
How often dup dup several times.
Every day.
You like one of them are healthy water drinker dudes.
I PLR.
Do you,
are you a healthy water drinker?
Dude?
Interesting detail.
This just happened.
Oh,
you ran out?
I don't know.
Uh,
hold on a second.
I to go to the recycling.
Got It's all right.
I'm pitching.
I've got a strong grip as you can move,
but it's all have to take it lightly.
Touching them.
A bottle.
A cop,
not a bottle.
Hold on,
hold on.
Oh,
model.
Seems like.
Oh man,
it's going back in though.
I can feel it starting to swell back yet.
That's unhealthy.
I'm putting,
I've been pitching too long.
Should I pay into the cup or bottle yet?
Oh,
you emptied it.
thanks man.
Oh yeah.
A lot went back into my urethra.
Ari should fear,
uh,
couldn't hold in his pee.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Couldn't means wouldn't filled up one Kombucha bottle.
Here's a cap they're feeling and then fill it up again.
I had to go empty it out for him.
Thanks for doing that.
Applies on the front.
Yeah.
I didn't want to leave you hanging in there,
dude.
Really?
There was only one solution.
I almost went to the kitchen sink and then I put it like,
Ooh.
Then we'd have to rinse that out.
That shit would be nasty there.
That bathroom sick as nasty.
You're going to have a cleaner in here?
No,
it's like,
it looks like a bachelor.
We're on our way out of the spot.
Oh Man.
It's not that bad.
I just use the time to fucking tweet about my new record saying had I kept
tweeting that James Comey was,
it was all code for my new record,
that he wanted people to buy it.
I know.
I saw some of the Instagram posts and how to call me endorsing your album.
Yeah.
He's a big fan.
He,
he,
he said he wanted to talk about it during the hearings cause that's a big
audience.
But apparently they wouldn't let them go.
Yeah.
Collusion between me and Comi would have fucked things up.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah,
it's uh,
well I actually,
it's funny cause this guy,
cause there's,
they say there's a chance which looking less like there's this guy Luke combs
who's like my arch nemesis even though he's a good dude.
I just,
he was up against me this week on the country charts cause my album comes out,
my new album came out this week and I'm trying to beat him.
And I said on Twitter that Russians have colluded with Sony records to like have
him outsell me and he kind of played along.
So we'll see.
I think,
I think they are,
I mean Nashville is definitely trying to keep me down,
but
are they really,
are they fucking with you?
Like how,
how were they receiving you now?
Now that you've become a mainstream success?
Cause I hear about you all the time.
Donald Cowboy Cerrone,
I think you know that he listens to your music before he goes out and fights.
Oh,
cowboy Cerrone reached out to me thanks to you.
He called,
he called me up and he was on the set of a movie with Michael Madsen and uh,
they go,
I don't know how it seems like last second,
but they go,
hey capital,
you had a scene tomorrow where you sing Karaoke with Michael Madsen.
And he saw you on saying,
and he's like,
fucking eating pussy kicking ass producers.
Like fuck you talking about.
He's like,
I want to sing eating pussy kicking ass.
do you have the rights to this song?
He's like,
I'll have it in like five minutes.
And he just fucking calls me.
I call my peoples like now I'm in a movie with cowboy Cerrone and Michael Madsen
singing and eating pussy kicking ass.
He said he was in the trailer,
you know,
like,
rehearsing with Michael Madsen and you know,
it gets to the sucking Dick Parker.
I think he was just like,
what the fuck we sing in here?
So it's just the,
uh,
it's the threat of losing everything in moderation.
Yeah.
Being ostracized by and just sort of expelled into this world that you believe
and have always believed is as evil and without
hope and doomed.
So how did you do it?
How did your,
your,
you got all your stuff packed.
People are coming in,
they're saying,
yeah.
I mean like they're,
they're,
they're trying to convince us,
but once they understand that we're not being convinced that,
that,
you know,
they,
they walked away.
So I mean that night our dad dropped us off at a hotel and then Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Like it's,
it's,
it's so immediate that you become this,
you become other,
you become an outsider.
Like in the next morning when we went back,
I rang the doorbell,
I rang the doorbell and I lived in that house from the day I was born.
Whoa.
Felt like you had to ring the doorbell.
This is not my world anymore.
Wow.
Chris was like,
why don't you ring the doorbell?
And it was like,
there's,
there's no other,
there is nothing else.
Like it's,
this is not our home.
It says not so we go and,
you know,
we're packing all of our things.
It was just,
it was awful just to,
I had been in those four months,
I had been so terrified of not knowing what was coming like this.
Imagine you're going to lose everyone in your life that they're just,
you're just going to like,
you're not going to like how your parents met and fell in love or like your
grandparents and family recipes and photos and memories and what did the house,
I'm like taking photos and voice recordings and just all the time,
like in every,
it was just,
it's just,
it's overwhelming.
It's just,
um,
it may be at least understand that the source of my dissatisfaction in life
wasn't internal.
It Wa it made sense.
It was that I was having a healthy reaction to circumstances in society that,
that humans were not adapted for.
And even that was enough to bring a kind of peace of mind for me.
Um,
I also very consciously and deliberately try to live in places where there is
the possibility of,
of um,
uh,
sort of close communal neighborhood.
I live in a very poor neighborhood in New York City at which for some of the
hassles at least has the sort of rich fabric of human connection that you just
don't get in wealthy neighborhoods.
So you'd do it on purpose.
Oh yeah.
What would,
I don't want you to say,
where do you want to say where you live?
I live in lower east side Manhattan and I mean,
he's not very,
very poor,
but it's,
it,
you know,
is a Dominican to Dominican neighborhood,
have half the people in that neighborhood really don't speak English very well.
So it's,
you know,
it's a very,
it's a very rich or ethnic neighborhood.
People are quite poor.
Um,
and,
and I know everybody and we,
everyone knows each other by sight and we look out for each other.
And it's,
I mean,
during hurricane,
a hurricane,
when hurricane sandy hit New York,
I mean,
a lot of the people that had young children had to leave because there was no
light,
there was no water.
The power was out right to half of Manhattan was completely dark.
It was really actually quite dangerous at night in the dark half a Manhattan
and,
uh,
where there was no streetlights.
And,
um,
so this building,
it's a tenement building that I live in with my wife and um,
and a lot of the people left and that they were worried about being robbed and
these are poor people,
right?
It is not a wealthy building at all,
is quite,
quite poor building.
And so they,
they,
they organized a guard shift.
One of the people,
one of the women in the building had a machete and they organized guard shifts
at the front door with a machete and the young,
the young men in the building took turns like two hours at a time guarding the
building with a machete.
Oh yeah.
And um,
you know,
I wasn't associated with the building at that time,
but boy would that have made me feel good to be part of that.
That,
you know what I mean?
Like that is what human beings,
that's what they are.
Right.
It's that right.
And you,
you didn't see that in a wealthy neighborhood,
partly because the wealthy neighborhoods actually had light.
Right.
Okay.